You are listening to radiolab radio from
W. N. Y. S. E. N. N. P. R. They got it. Okay. They got it. What up ladies?
Hey, how's it going at Jad? It is. Yeah,
it is indeed. Hey. Hi. Yay. This is Jad Abumrad, this is the radio lab today.
Robert and I invited two folks into the studio. Our former producer,
Lulu Miller basically started the show with us. She's even in the Sonic Id.
You can hear it right there. Say Okay. Okay. And we brought,
we invited her in and also Elise Spiegel reporter at NPR because Lulu and Elise
together are starting new radio show and a podcast and everyone's very excited
about it. It's called Invisibilia. So like a Latin word. What does that,
it is a Latin word. It's a name that my mother came up with.
This is the least talking. Um,
cause she's a French video blister and so they just like no stuff like that.
Under what circumstances did this come up? We were just, you know,
hang in the way that the Spiegels hang in like her bedroom. And I was like,
but this is what the show is about.
It's about all these invisible things to and physical,
but they're affecting you. And what's the name? And she was just like,
why don't you just call it Invisibilia did a little, oh, I was like,
and I'm glad for what invisible things.
So the show promises to be sort of an investigation of all the invisible things
that, uh, guide our behavior that we generally don't see now.
They've been sharing some stories that they've been working on as they're going.
And a lot of it is kind of amazing. So we, uh,
we asked them if we could preview, uh, one of their stories for you guys. Uh,
this one that you're going to hear comes from an hour that they're producing,
uh, on the topic of categories like, uh, the different, uh,
boxes that we put things in our world into.
And the first piece in the show looks at one of the most basic categories that
there is the first question that any buddy asks a parent who has a new baby.
Is it a boy or girl? I have to say in my career,
I have done a number of stories about blurring between boy and girl,
but the story I'm about to tell you is about a kind of blurring that I had never
heard of before.
This is a person I met who calls herself Paige Abendroth.
Evan Roth means the color of the sky when it's that deep red.
Right before the sunsets, Paige had bright blue eyes,
long black hair and a ponytail. Go ahead and make yourself think.
We were in San Diego by the way, setting ourselves up to talk.
I'm going to make you skip, skip, skip, skip, skip it. Let's get together.
So after we sat down,
I asked page to show me some pictures of herself from about a decade before.
So there aren't many in the pictures. Was a man,
a man in a naval uniform. He was very buff. Strapping,
yeah, very military.
I had a high and tight haircut and there they were.
Those bright blue eyes. You look very, you look pretty conservative here too.
Yes I do.
Right
page. Spent the first three decades of her life as a man,
but let me be clear from the top pages.
Story is not the transgender story that you typically hear.
Typically people who are transgender,
I feel like they are one gender trapped in the body of the other gender.
Their internal gender identity is misaligned with their biological sex,
but it's static. It stays the same.
But when I was talking to Paige that didn't capture her experience at all
because when I met her page was flipping,
flipping between the category male and the category female.
I flipped back and forth multiple times a day.
I'll say maybe you spend 20% of my time in guy mode and the rest of it and
female mode.
One morning Paige would wake up feeling strongly that the gender at the core of
her being was female,
but then suddenly it's just kind of like there was a change and page was in guy
mode. When that happened,
all kinds of things about page changed,
her posture changed and my weight kind of moves up to my shoulders.
Like my center of gravity is kind of up here more significantly.
She told me there was a real psychological shift.
The way I see the world and the way I interpret the world is different.
When Paige was in male mode,
Paige was less interested in people in talking to them,
in making eye contact with them.
I'm a lot more introverted. I'm a lot more, I'm quieter,
but in female mode she was much more expansive and sights,
sounds, smells, likes, dislikes. They were all different. When I'm female,
all my emotions are like just really vivid, like colors.
Basically.
Paige was constantly and very abruptly bounced between two starkly different
ways of being in and filtering the world page wasn't able to dictate when or
where this happened. I really have no control over it.
She'd be sitting in her office talking to her boss and Bam.
She'd be walking down the street, Bam.
Now when this happened,
it wasn't like page was an entirely different person.
I'm always the same person. I the world differently,
but I'm still me. I still am in control of myself.
I still have my same wants and desires.
There was just this profound difference beneath everything.
It's just a sense of knowing,
like the way that you know you're a female right now without having to be told.
It's the same way that I know that I'm a female and when I'm a guy,
it's the same way. I know I'm a guy.
It's just this instinctual knowing of what I am. Yeah.
[inaudible]
by the way, right now, are you male or female?
Definitely in girl mind. Yeah. And how long have you been in girl mode?
Right now? I'm bout an hour, I'd say.
So maybe you're thinking that page seems nuts.
[inaudible] Paige herself has had that thought.
I thought that I was going crazy. Yeah. I mean, um,
some people first hear about this, um, you know,
they may wonder if it's dissociative identity disorder,
which is formerly known as multiple personality disorder or a form of psychosis.
This is Laura Case,
a researcher who has worked in the lab of a very famous neurologist amend named
V s Rama Shondra and [inaudible].
And a couple of years ago they got an email from a woman describing exactly the
same kind of experience.
That page describes someone who experiences this switching back and forth.
And while on the one hand they were dubious,
we get a lot of interesting emails in our lab emails from people claiming all
kinds of wild sounding experiences. On the other hand,
they study the brain and they have seen brains do all kinds of things.
They've seen brains that suddenly stop recognizing faces,
brains that think their owner has a mysterious limb. So they were curious,
here's a person who goes back and forth in terms of what their brain seems to be
telling them about whether they're male or female.
How fascinating would that be to look and see what could be changing in the
brain, um, or in their environment to be causing that shift in identity.
So they decided to look into it over the past couple of years,
case has found dozens of people with this experience and case has started
testing them in different ways, including giving them psychological screenings.
And what she found was that as a group,
these people are not mentally unstable.
They simply don't have dissociative identity disorder.
None of them had any form of psychosis or anything like that.
They ruled out bipolar, schizophrenia and saw some other interesting things.
They were actually a little bit more ambidextrous,
more than the general population.
Basically they found enough to suggest that there might be something
neurological going on. So they published a very, very small study,
a preliminary sort of report in a journal called medical hypotheses and then
started on another study. But we're not, not ready to, um,
talk the data from that study. I did though,
get one tidbit about this from case, and again,
this is very, very, very, very preliminary,
but she found that the same person will perform differently on certain tests
depending on whether they are in male or female mode. For example,
she gave the same person these mental puzzles that test spacial and language
abilities. And Lulu, you know how men are really good at, um,
supposedly men are really good at kind of spatial directions and they're like
spatial manipulation. What does that mean?
I don't know how to explain it exactly,
but like you're a woman so you wouldn't understand and so I wouldn't understand
it very well. Right. I'm like,
take a geometric shape rotated in your mind, stuff like that. Okay.
They found when they gave these tests to these people when they were in their
different states, they had different abilities. Oh Wow.
So like when they were men,
they performed more as men and when they were women they performed more as
women. Whoa. Yeah.
We did see some differences between gender six that were intriguing.
Um, but not conclusive. Anyway, here's the point.
There is some evidence that the shifts these people say that they are
experiencing could be real,
which brings us back to page. You know, I wake up in the morning, I'm like,
am I male and a female?
I wanted to talk to her about what it was like to move in this way between
categories.
So let's just start with like your childhood now.
Page didn't start off this way. She started off as a hey,
who really didn't even have that experience that you sometimes hear about where
people described feeling from a very early age,
like they're trapped in the wrong body. I mean,
I love playing with Jay Jos and as a teen to,
he was a boy obsessed with the things that most boys are obsessed with.
I always thought about women, you never thought you were good.
Still Page says there were these strange momentary flashes that were disturbing.
I remember looking at girls and um,
not just being attracted to them but thinking that I was supposed to be them and
wishing that I could kind of go over to the girl group and be accepted because
that's where I felt I should be. But these thoughts were really inconsistent.
It's not, I didn't always feel that way. So Paige grows up,
graduated from high school,
goes to college and then really starts to struggle.
The flashes are still there, college is hard,
page drops out and begins to feel really, really lost.
And then in a somewhat odd place, page finds relief
in the navy. I love the discipline of it. The structure of it. First of all,
for some reason those flashes go way down. Why?
I don't know. I saw myself as being more of a guy than I ever did before,
but really it was while stationed at a naval base in Japan.
The page found relief in a way that will be familiar to many of you.
I walked around the corner and I saw her and she was just kind of bouncing
around and she was very energetic and it was love at first sight.
Immediately I knew that there was something like special about her and even
though page had never been a very aggressive person page completely went after
this girl. I was smitten.
I was immediately smitten and it worked.
We were just like this, we so in tune with one another.
I mean we knew each other so good.
We can communicate like with a series of clicks, like what do you mean?
And like the other person would answer back and we know what we were like
getting it in. Sometimes it would mean like,
do you mean like how are you? Or it could just be acknowledging that you know,
you're there.
So began the best chapter in pages. Like,
I can't wait, you're recording this. They get married, they moved to California,
got a home, a car, had a steady job.
I had everything that I ever wanted. Okay,
what does that mean? It depends on the context.
[inaudible]
and then page turns 30 and all of a sudden starts feeling really,
really tired. I mean just coming up the steps I would run out of breath.
So page goes to see the doctor
and eventually what they finally figured out was that my body thought it'd be a
really fun joke on me to stop producing testosterone.
Basically at 30 years old, I had the testosterone level of an 80 plus year old
man.
So the doctors put page on testosterone replacement therapy and very quickly the
exhaustion went away. Physically, I felt like I had before,
but the flashes there back with a vengeance,
I would have those
feelings again where I thought I was supposed to be female, except it wasn't.
There wasn't anything subtle about it.
It was a very strong feeling that something had gone terribly wrong
in that I was not supposed to be male
in these moments. Page would look down at her body,
this hard torso covered in hair
and feel utter disgust.
Imagine you woke up and your body was a cockroach.
It was really unsettling. Did you,
so did you start talking to your wife about it? No, I was terrified.
Um, I thought I was going crazy. Um,
I didn't want her to think less of me and uh,
it was something that I kept inside.
[inaudible] Paige started telling me that occasionally during this period to
ease this feeling of disgust that came over her when she flipped into female
mode but had a male body,
she would secretly put on women's clothing.
She felt a need to cover this body that felt so wrong with clothes from the
right sack. It's just, I was just trying to do anything I could to,
to make myself feel more female.
So I started asking questions about this.
Do you remember the first time you decided to do that?
[inaudible] but suddenly the whole tone of the conversation changed.
I don't want to talk about it.
Okay.
All right. So when was so after that, what happened? So we like you,
um, do you need to take a break?
Um, yeah, I'm cool. Yes, you're cool. You want to take a break or yes.
You're not cool. Yeah. Okay. Sure.
Paige got up and disappeared around the corner.
I could hear the faucet running in the bathroom and when she came back she
wanted me to know something. Um, if it matters, I flipped back into game mode.
Okay. So the, is that why you don't want to talk? It's just kind of like,
it's just different now you flipped into guy mode.
Was it when your eyes closed that you flipped into guy mode? I don't know.
So are you in guy mode right this second?
[inaudible] so is it hard to answer questions? [inaudible]
okay. Okay. I can, I'll be okay. I just need like a little bit,
we sat awkwardly for a while. Neither of us quite sure what to do.
It did feel like there was a difference in page even in the way that she talked
about. So how are you doing? I'm good. Are you male or female? No.
Okay. Is that okay? Yeah.
Let's do this next year.
We're going to do it in just one minute after we take a quick break.
This is Candace currently calling from her bicycle.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org thank you.
Hey guys, this is Alison calling from Luxembourg.
Radiolab is supported by rocket mortgage by quicken loans.
Rocket mortgage brings the mortgage process into the 21st century.
With this completely online process,
safely share your bank statements and pay stubs with the touch of a button.
Ditch the paperwork and use your phone or tablet to get approved for purchase or
refinance in minutes.
Get a custom mortgage solution whenever and wherever you want.
Check out rocket mortgage
today@quickenloansdotcomslashradiolabequalhousinglenderlicensedinallfiftystatesandmlsconsumeraccess.org
number 30 30 hi
rapid quilt, which Radiolab is supported by Google and Squarespace.
Make your business official with Google and Squarespace.
When you create a custom domain and a beautiful business website with
Squarespace, you'll receive a free year of business,
email and professional tools from Google.
It's the simplest way to look professional online.
Visit squarespace.com/google to start your free trial.
Use the offer code document for 10% off on your first purchase.
Google and Squarespace. Make it professional. Make it beautiful.
We're back. This is radio lab bringing you a, a preview of the new NPR show.
Invisibilia and we'll continue with our story about page. Evan drouth gears,
elite Spiegel to pick up the tail
page,
explained that the next chapter of her life involved finding a name for what was
going on with her by gender,
people who consider themselves both female and male at the same time,
she found it on a bigender website and though only a small portion of the people
on the website described flipping like page,
it felt like this could be an explanation.
The way I felt was other people felt that way and it was, it was real.
It wasn't, you know, just some weird psychological construct.
But with this validation came a horrible realization.
Paige had to tell her why I told her that we needed to talk and so sat down in
separate chairs. I think I was on a couch and she was on a,
her recliner page was terrified.
She was certain that her marriage would be over and she was very visibly upset.
Sorry.
I was just
God.
Oh. It was just begging her to,
to not leave and to accept me for who I was.
I couldn't, I lived for her for so long.
I didn't know I could live with that.
Uh Huh.
To page a surprise. Her wife said it's okay.
She told me that everything was going to be okay and that, you know,
we're gonna make this work and, and she wasn't gonna give up on me.
[inaudible]
page couldn't believe how lucky she was
together. They walked into this space between categories.
Some mornings. Paige would wake up male, the husband,
her wife had married that men would put on male clothes, go to work,
other mornings paid would wake up female,
a woman trapped in this strange body and they were doing it,
helping each other through life in this odd space.
Okay,
but one problem remain as much as the two of them could get used to the idea of
flipping
page couldn't get used to the physical experience of it.
I came out of the shower one day and I had gone in and guy mode.
I came out and female Moan.
She was standing there beginning to dry off and I saw myself in the mirror and I
was so disgusted that I threw up these kinds of feelings happened all of the
time. Now Paige had come across a potential cure for this,
a sort of homespun remedy that some of the bigender folks had written about
online. It involved hormones.
Page would go on estrogen to make her body more androgynous.
Bring my body too.
Yeah,
an androgynous point where I could present both as either male or female.
Apparently it would reduce the shock of being thrown between categories so
violently if her body was in a permanent state of inbetween.
So Paige decided to try it.
She began estrogen treatments and it worked.
The first time I got my first injection,
I just felt this immense relief like I was finally on the right track.
There was no longer the same physical discomfort,
but as Paige finally was becoming comfortable in her own body,
page's wife started to turn away. They began sleeping in different bedrooms.
It was almost like we were becoming strangers and one there just came a point
where I realized that, you know, she wasn't suddenly gonna.
I don't know except you.
She tried really hard
[inaudible]
but it's really difficult
when things don't have a clear category that's scary for us all there are sheep
we don't recognize.
I felt like a monster.
I felt like
this terrible like alien creature that had come down and taken over her
husband's life and
taking him away from her.
One night I heard her crying in the bathroom and I asked her if everything was
okay and she said no, and she said, it's over, isn't it?
And I think the next day she told me to move out.
I mourned for my marriage the same way I would mourn for like, you know,
the death of, you know, my mother or someone who I was really,
really close with.
See, right now I just,
it's really hard to talk about still sitting there in page's apartment,
the afternoon light fading in the window behind her.
I was just struck by how hard her situation was.
It's not just the fact that page wasn't in one clear gender category.
She was stuck between categories in other ways as well.
In the weeks before and after our visit,
I had called around trying to get a handle on how to make sense of this
experience that people like page describe.
I had spoken to all kinds of people, therapists, historians,
gender researchers,
but it seemed like a lot of the people that I spoke to were convinced that the
experience I was describing didn't really exist.
There's no way they're actually flipping between genders.
I was told by two different gender researchers into different European
countries. These people are just psychotic.
Both of the men who told me this had worked in gender research for their entire
professional careers and they sounded extremely confident.
A gender therapist in San Francisco was also skeptical,
but she had a different reason.
These people are actually just normal transgendered people.
She explained in the sense that they are experiencing the same things that any
transgender person experiences,
they've just developed a different way of describing it. Same experience.
Different labels seem to be her argument. In other words,
it's not just that page was existing between genders.
The problem was even more profound.
Most of the people that I talked to didn't seem to believe that the experience
that Paige was saying that she had was real
like, why do you think this happened to you?
Like where does this come from in you? I don't know.
I've stopped asking myself that because it doesn't matter anymore where it came
from. I just kind of am what I am.
When we talked page seemed as mystified by what was happening to her as anyone
else,
but her experience she concluded was her experience.
There wasn't that much she could do about it.
Like my biggest worry is that I'm never going to really fit in to like female
spaces or male spaces.
I am afraid that I'm going to be living the rest of my life in some kind of
weird gender twilight zone.
And what will you do then?
I don't know.
I'll keep on doing my best
[inaudible]
more than a year after we first met, I called Paige up on the phone.
I wanted to check in and see how she was doing and it was clear from the very
first moment she answered that something was different.
Her voice sounded different. Higher. Hello? Hi. Can you hear me?
Yeah. I can.
Turns out about six months after I went to San Diego,
the flippings started to fade and eventually Paige had settled full time into
being a woman.
The last time page had flipped into being psychologically male was in the fast
food restaurant, five guys, and she said it took her completely by surprise.
I've gotten so used to constantly spaying like I am, you know,
now as a woman that I've thought it had stopped and I remember I flipped her
really hard. It was, it was really bizarre.
I felt like I was wearing a a really uncomfortable sweater or something like
that.
No page.
Couldn't really explain why the flipping had stopped any better than she could
explain why it had started.
She said she thought the estrogen hormones she'd taken to make her body more
androgynous probably had affected her and Laura Case,
the researcher who's been studying people like page agrees that hormones do
affect the brain, but still there was no way to be absolutely certain,
but there was one thing,
the page seemed absolutely clear about living in one category.
Even if it's a category that's often discriminated against,
like transgendered women is way better than having no category.
Oh my goodness. Yes. It's so much easier.
It's so much more manageable in the world to me. Just,
it makes so much more sense
now. Paige knew what she was supposed to do where she could place her foot.
She didn't have a wife, but she did have that
[inaudible] [inaudible]
what I really want to know since I have never heard of anybody like this,
I didn't know this was this was in the inhuman experience.
Are there a lot of these people, I mean is there like a teeny,
teeny handful or is this so,
so I have spoken to maybe six people who have alternating gender Incan crudity
who flipped,
who are there by gender and they kind of moved between their genders in this way
because there are lots of different ways of being by gender. Right. Um,
and click thing, never surprising the other people you spoke with,
was it also suddenly like that? Yes. So they, they had that too, Huh? Yes.
Any idea what causes those sudden flips and exactly what Laura Case is trying to
understand?
I think she has about 26 if these people that she has been talking to. And, um,
so she has been talking to these people, but I don't know that it's clear yet.
It could be biological or it could be a different kind of disorder.
It could simply be a different way of conceptualizing and experience that a lot
of different people have.
We can't even say this is a condition with a strong in sharpie marker
declaration of now there's a name and now this exists.
Like there could be hundreds or thousands of people privately sitting with this,
and if, if that name came out, maybe they'd suddenly have a place.
But the name right now itself is like in gray translucence.
What is the name again? Alternating gender in congruity.
What you're saying is this is really a mystery.
You don't really know what happened in the story. I mean,
that's the, that's is in no category.